each of the corals that we have here
fits into a particular spot depending on
the amount of light that it needs an
amount of water motion that it needs
there was a lot of complex engineering
that went into creating the water motion
systems of the circulation systems on
this exhibit there are three very large
pump forty horsepower pumps that drive
manifolds of nozzles that are at
alternating so it'll the water current
will come from one direction for two
minutes and then two minutes later it
comes from a different direction we did
a one year long sunlight study of the
site to determine what the best
placement was for the rainforest and the
coral reef exhibits which are the most
sort of light needy exhibits that we
have so early on in the design of those
exhibits were in different places in the
building and they actually got shuffled
around in order to place the coral reef
in a spot where made most use of the
natural sunlight
we're here with Bart Shepherd Steinhart
aquarium biologist and he's going to
tell us about the process of introducing
coral into this new environment well
what we wanted to do is create a very
large and elaborate coral reef tank one
thing that we didn't want to do was go
out into the wild and
natural reefs once the word kind of got
out that we were trying to grow corals
and you throw a coral reef in a
sustainable manner we had all kinds of
people from local hobbyists and local
aquarium societies donate large pieces
of coral to us what we did was take
those corals plant them onto rocks using
a special glue Lock them onto the rock
and then grow them into larger colonies
each individual piece was then brought
over here in the back of a truck packed
in styrofoam boxes or in large plastic
coolers and hand placed in a specific
location and we take lots of pieces from
the same species of coral we've put them
on rocks together and then we grow lots
of rocks and have lots of little
branches on it then we put those all
those rocks together I'm going to create
the illusion of a much larger much older
colony there are a number of different
types of corals generally we've turned
them hard corals and soft corals most of
the corals that are in this tank right
now are the hard corals and those are
corals that actually make a limestone
skeleton they're the ones that are out
there building coral reefs they take
calcium and carbonates from the water
and they make rock out of it so they're
basically making rock out of water and
people think of coral they don't really
think of agression but but coral is a
very aggressive organism and if a lot of
corals will produce stinging stem cells
very powerful stinging tentacles called
sweeper tentacles that they put out into
the water surrounding them to try and
sting and kill anything that comes up
close into the neighboring vicinity we
had to leave a lot of space between the
galaxia coral and its neighbors because
those sweeper tentacles can be up to
about a foot long and they'll just lay
them on another coral and sting it and
try and kill it the coral itself is
actually a colony of maybe thousands of
individual animals and each one of those
little animals is called a polyp and
each polyp may not live for thousands of
years but that community they're all
connected they're all their tissues
connected they all live together they're
all clones from an original founder
olive
that community can live on for thousands
of years if the conditions are right
you